uh let me ask the most ridiculous
question you think p
equals np wow i don't know
i mean i would say
i i know there are enough people who
have very strong interest in trying to
show that it is i'm talking about
government
agencies
for security purposes repurposing and
most computer scientists which would say
believe that p
equals np uh my question almost like
this is back to our aliens discussion
you want to think outside the box the
the low probability event what is the
world
what kind of discoveries would lead us
to to
to prove that p does not equal to np
like there could be giant
misunderstandings
or gaps in our knowledge about computer
science about theoretical computer
science about computation
which allow us to think like flatten all
problems
yeah so i don't know the answer to this
question i think i think it's very
interesting but i
actually i know let's put it this way by
being at carnegie mellon and being
around the theoretical computer
scientists
i know enough about what i don't know
what to say i'm wrong to be humble
i'm the only person to answer this
question yeah yeah
it's a great one well scott aaronson
who's now here at ut
austin he used to be at mit well puts
the probability
of um p and p not equals to n p
at three percent he put it's i you know
i always love it when you ask
it's very rare in science in in
academics because you're
because most folks are humble
in in the face of the mystery the
uncertainty of everything around us
to have the the both the humor and the
guts to say um
like what are the chance that there's um
aliens in our galaxy intelligent alien
civilizations
as opposed to saying i don't know it
could be you know it could be zero it
could be depending on the fact just
saying
it's two point five percent there's
something very pleasant about just
having uh
it's the the it's the number thing um
that's power to the number it's just
like 42 it's like why 40 i don't know
but it's a powerful number
and then everything this is the power of
human psychology is once you have the
number 42
it's not that the number has meaning but
because
it's placed in a book with humor around
it
it has the meme effect of actually
creating reality i mean you could say
that 42 has a strong contribution
of helping us colonize mars because it
created
it gave the whatever existential crisis
to many of us including elon musk when
he was young
you know reading a book like that and
then like now 42 is not part of his
humor
that he doesn't shut up about it's
constantly joking about and that humor
is spreading through our minds
and somehow this like silly number just
had an effect in that same way
after scott told me like the three
percent chance
it's stuck in my head and i think it's
been having a ripple effect in everybody
else
the believing that p is not equal to np
scott almost as a joke saying it's three
percent is making it's actually
motivating a large number of researchers
to work on it
it's very high because for the potential
impact that that would happen
but then three percent is not that high
because it's only you know it's
like we're not very good i feel like
humans are only able to really think
about like
one percent 50 and we kind of
i think a lot of people around three
percent up to 50 percent
like in our minds like three percent
like this
it could happen it could happen and it
could happen it's like
yeah like half the time it'll probably
happen
so we're not very good at that that's
that's the other thing with the pandemic
is uh
we're not the exponential growth that we
also talked about offline
uh is uh something that we can't quite
intuit
and that's something we probably should
if we were to predict the future to
anticipate the future and to understand
how to create technologies that
let us sort of control the future
you